[Musique]
c'est en musique qu'on démarrait les
festivités du 63e anniversaire de
l'indépendance de Madagascar ce vendredi
7 juillet au palais de la source une
cérémonie officielle qui s'est tenue en
présence du président du Département
Cyril Melchior de la visconcule de
Madagascar à la réunion des conseillers
départementaux des représentants de la
préfecture de la région de la ville de
Saint-Denis ainsi que des responsables
d'associations de l'île c'est la 19e
édition de cette célébration de la fête
malgache ici au département nous avons
une histoire commune nous avons une
communauté de destin dans la zone
Océan Indien le peuplement de la Réunion
c'est aussi bien évidemment et on le
sait ben des personnes venant de
Madagascar et aussi bien par le passé
comme pour le présent et pour l'avenir
et bien Madagascar est la réunion vivent
cette communauté de destin comme je l'ai
dit c'est quoi cela que nous célébrons
cette amitié les invités ont découvrir
la richesse de l'artisanat et de la
culture malgache dans un palais de la
source décoré pour l'occasion aux
couleurs de la grande île en tout cas
c'est une belle soirée comme ça toujours
été le cas l'année dernière c'est ma
deuxième fois d'assister à une
célébration de fête nationale donnée par
le Conseil départemental mais j'espère
toujours que ça permettra ça permettra
aux deux parties de continuer une
relation fructueuse comme toujours ça
fait plaisir de revenir ici et de
représenter tous les malgages de la
Réunion un moment de convivialité et de
partage qui témoignent encore une fois
de la fraternité entre Madagascar et la
Réunion
[Musique]